[Musique]
montigny le bretonneux les
commémorations du 11-novembre commencé
dès le 10 au soir la ville faisait
partie des 35 communes de france à
accueillir la flamme du souvenir de
l'arc de triomphe
c'est émouvant et c'est c'est
impressionnant d'avoir la flamme
la flamme a fait un parcours dans toute
la ville entre les mains d'un jeune et
d'un ennemi pour un devoir de mémoire
inter générationnelle moi j'ai emmené
j'emmenais mes fils à 2,6 et et novembre
pour qu elles pour qu'elles sachent
aussi ce qui s'est passé et puis c'est
important de son enfance et bien c'est
bien il faut transmettre
il faut transmettre notre notre passé à
nos à nos enfants pour qu'ils sachent
pas ce que c'est l'histoire de france
puisque c'est une histoire qui nous qui
nous concerne tous donc c'est important
je crois que pour la ville de montigny
c'est quelque chose qui va rester
marquée dans les esprits de tous nos
habitants
d'ailleurs jacques abord rien que déjà
ce soir comme comment
combien ils sont nombreux
il était tout aussi nombreux le
lendemain à braver la pluie pour la
cérémonie
la flamme est allumée face au monument
aux morts face à 250 enfants dont
certains ont pu lire des lettres de paul
matte
il va retrouver ton pays devenu français
jeanne a été gazé sur le front et les
morts d'épuisement dans les années 1920
or de 26 enfants ont également déclamer
les noms des vingt six 6 ni montant
tombé durant cette première guerre
mondiale
on attrape aussi le partage entre
générations était de mise de nombreux
jeunes étaient présents et ont largement
participé à la cérémonie
c'est important oui surtout pour pour
tous celui qu'ils ont combattu
même pour nous un peu nos petits-enfants
savoir des commémorations pour se
souvenir qu'ils ont réuni les citoyens
de vous tous les monuments aux morts de
france
[Musique]